Joneja: Good morning
and welcome.
I am Navneet Joneja,
the product manager for
Google Storage for Developers,
and with me is Mike Schwartz,
an engineer on the team.
We're here to talk to you
about how you can store
your application's data
in the Google Cloud.
So we're going to begin
today's session
with a quick introduction
to the product
and talk to you
about some new features
we're announcing
at I/O this morning.
We'll then walk you through
getting started
with using Google Storage,
some more advanced features,
several of which are new
this morning,
and then put it all together
with a comprehensive
end-to-end scenario.
Now, there's a lot more
to the product
than we can cover
in a one-hour session,
but we'll try to hit
all the highlights.
So what is Google Storage?
At its core, it's a service that
allows you to store your data
on Google's proven
storage infrastructure.
It's designed to be
extremely reliable
with multiple layers
of redundancy built in.
It's also designed to be
very scalable and fast.
We've brought
our many years of innovation
in online storage and networking
to bear on this product
so you have a product
that scales seamlessly,
and is extremely fast.
As the name suggests,
Google Storage has
a developer and business focus,
but there's nothing
stopping you using it
for personal use as well.
Several of us do.
The product
has a REST API,
which is basically
the standard HTTP semantics,
and is supported by many
third-party tools and libraries,
several of which
are Open Source.
Authentication and sharing
is extremely flexible,
allowing you to implement
a wide variety of use cases.
We'll talk about some of those
later in the session today.
And the service features
strong data consistency.
So, last year at I/O,
we introduced into
an invitation-only preview
a product
that was very simple,
developer oriented,
scaled well,
extremely reliable,
very fast,
and put you in control
of your data
and gave you mechanisms
to share it.
So, this year we're taking
those three themes
and deepening our focus
in each of those areas.
We're focusing
more on the developer
by moving to a more
team-based account model,
which maps more naturally
to how teams of people
work on a product.
And along with that,
we're moving management
of Google Storage
over to the API's console,
the Google API's console,
where you manage
all your other APIs,
so you can manage them,
all the interactions,
from one common place.
We're also introducing
several new features
in the areas of scalability
and performance,
starting with raising the size
of objects you can store
in Google Storage
to five terabytes,
up from a terabyte
last year.
We're also introducing
a new storage region in Europe,
so you can choose
to store your data
either in the U.S. or Europe
and get the same high levels
of reliability, scalability,
and performance
and the exact
same set of features
regardless of where
you choose to store your data.
We're also announcing support
for streaming uploads
into Google Storage.
The benefit of this is you
no longer need to buffer data
on your servers.
If you're trying
to get data from, say,
an external telemetry source
or from an end-user
into the Cloud,
you can just sta--
start sending it
straight into the Cloud
by using the standard
HTTP chunked transfer
encoding mechanism.
So, it's very easy and makes--
that use gets a lot easier.
And finally, Google believes
strongly in simplicity,
and Google believes in speed,
and we're bringing
those two together
by building a performance
that performs really well
without any additional
complexity, just works.
So, a great example of that is--
One of the common models
when serving data
over the Internet
to a wide variety of users,
some of whom may be, you know,
across the globe,
is you find a reliable place
to store your data,
and then you stick an edge cache
or CDN around it.
With Google Storage,
you don't need to do that.
It just works.
So, I talked a bit about how
we're deepening our focus
on sharing and controlling
your data,
and we have several
new features in that area
to announce today as well,
starting with support
for OAuth 2.0, the standard,
which allows you to do
a bunch of very interesting
sharing and authentication
authorization mechanisms.
Moving to a more project-based
ACL model,
so, you know, in conjunction
with the team-based
account model for using storage,
you can set
ACLs in a project-based manner
so you can easily
set up accounts and ACLs
that work for your team.
Of course, you can
always override that,
but we wanted to make it easy
for you to get started.
And finally,
we got a lot of feedback
from our community
that sharing was great,
but they didn't necessarily
want to have all the people
they had sign up
and share their data
have Google Storage accounts.
So, we're happy
to announce today
that, as of today,
you no longer need to have
your partners and customers
have Google accounts
to share your data.
They can just have
a Google account,
and you can share data
with them.
And we're also
very happy to announce
that for those of you
who have been waiting
for an interview to use--
sorry--
an invitation
to use the service,
the wait is now over.
We're generally available,
and we also have
a free trial here
with a limited quota
of bandwidth, storage,
and requests
through the end of the year.
So, great.
We have a bunch of new features.
We're generally available.
And you can get started
for free,
but what do you want to use
Google Storage for?
Well, we've designed the service
to be extremely generic,
so you can use it
for almost anything.
You're limited
by your imagination.
But having said that,
there's probably
about five main buckets
into which we see
our users falling.
The first is storing data
for applications,
a great example of which is,
for example,
if you want to have, say,
a photo-editing application
and you want to store
photographs somewhere,
you can store the photographs
in Google Storage.
If you have a data-sharing
mechanism you want to implement,
we talked
about the number of features
we implemented in that area
to make that easier.
Storing data for computation
is also a great use
for Google Storage,
and a great example of that
is the Google Prediction API,
so for those of you who
haven't yet encountered that,
it's a product that allows you
to use Google's
proprietary machine
learning tools
to detect patterns and meaning
in existing data sets
and then to use that knowledge
to predict the meaning
of new data sets.
It's a great product--
if that sounds interesting,
there's actually a session
on that tomorrow as well.
Static content hosting
is also a very common use case
in Google Storage,
and I talked about the fact
that performance just works,
and because
of our HTTP REST API,
it's a very natural fit.
And finally, if you have
high-value data
that you want to make sure
is either backed up
or archived to the Cloud
so you can either pull it down
reliably and quickly
if something goes wrong,
or you want to CloudBurst,
or you just want to have
a secondary copy available
that you load balance across
or distribute, that's another
great use for Google Storage.
We believe there's no greater
endorsement for a product
than that Google is willing
to bet its own businesses on it,
and Google Storage has seen very
wide adoption across Google.
So, with that, I'd like
to bring on Mike Schwartz,
who'll walk you through
using the product.
Schwartz:
Thanks, Navneet.
So, I'm going to talk today
about the various aspects,
most basically,
the basic API,
and then
the more advanced aspects
that we're introducing today,
and then provide
an end-to-end scenario.
Before I do that,
I want to just go back
to this slide
that Navneet just had up.
You probably noticed
my picture there,
so there's a lot of products
inside of Google
that use Google Storage.
The reason my picture's up there
is, several months ago,
I decided to move all the data
out of my house,
all of my personal data out of
the house into Google Storage,
and so now I just have
browsers in my home,
and that's, again,
an endorsement
for how much I believe
in the product.
Okay, so first step
I want to show you,
it's pretty quick and easy to
get started using Google Storage
and for this,
if you go to that link.
Actually,
starting this afternoon,
that link will be live.
Once you get to that link,
you'll get to a--
you'll click through,
and you'll get to a page
called the Google APIs page,
and from here, you can sign up
for a variety of different APIs.
As you can see,
there's quite a few.
And what you want to do is get
down to the storage link
and click on
"enable storage,"
and once you do that,
you'll be presented
with some terms of service,
which you can read
and agree to,
and then
once you finish that,
then you just need to
sign up for billing,
and I've already
enabled this account
and set it up for billing.
And at this point, I can come in
and start using Google Storage.
And for this purpose,
I want to show you first,
we have a simple command
line tool called "gsutil,"
and gsutil has
a number of UNIX-like commands
built into it.
So, the first one
I want to use
is to create a bucket
called "gsdemo2011,"
and once I've done that,
I can upload data
into the Cloud.
So, for example,
I'm going to use the gsutil copy
and similarly to UNIX,
copy "-r" will
recursively copy everything
that starts with "data."
I'm using
a wild card there.
I have a half dozen files
like that,
and once I finish copying all
those clouds up in the Cloud,
all those files up
into the Cloud,
I can look and see what's--
what's in the--
I can look and see
what's there,
and I can also use
the gsutil "ls-l" command
and this will give me
a little more detail,
some object sizes
and time stamps and so forth.
Okay, so that gets some data
up into the Cloud.
And then one other thing
I want to demonstrate here
is it's equally easy
to get your data
right back out of the Cloud,
and for that purpose,
I'm just going to reverse
the order of the recursive copy
and copy down
to a local directory,
and it's as easy as that.
And that's actually
an important point to us.
At Google, we believe
your data belongs to you,
and it should be really easy
to get your data completely out
anytime that you want.
So, there it is in a nutshell,
getting started.
Just sign up,
agree to terms of service,
set up billing,
and you can start
using the service.
Now I want to talk
about the API.
So, as we've
already alluded to,
Cloud storage is organized
into buckets and objects
and you can create
as many buckets as you want,
but in practice,
most users just create one
or maybe a handful
of buckets,
and then they load that bucket
up with many, many objects.
You can have
millions of objects
that can be anywhere
from a few bytes to terabytes,
any format of data
that you want.
And then the--the basic API
uses REST, which stands as--
stands for "representational
state transfer,"
which is just the principle
behind HTTP.
Basically, everything's
named with your eyes
and acted on with
a simple handful of verbs,
"GET," "HOST," "PUT,"
and so forth.
And so, here's an example of
uploading a file to the Cloud
called "data.csv,"
and it's going to upload it
into the bucket "gsdemo2011,"
and there's
an authorization header.
I'll talk about that
a bit later.
And then
that basic REST request
can be modified
using HTTP headers.
So, for example,
you can set content type
and encoding this way.
You can control
caching this way.
By default,
objects are not cache-able,
but you can make them
cache-able
for a variety of
performance-enhancement reasons.
So that's the basic API.
And now what
I want to point out is
we have a couple of layers
of reference implementation.
So, you could just
write a piece of code
that talks directly using HTTP,
and that's pretty
straightforward to do.
There's a lot of language
or level libraries
that make that
pretty easy to do,
but once you start using some
of the more involved features,
it can be
a little bit complicated.
For example, if you ever need
to implement signing
like HMAC signing for--
for authentication,
or if you wanted to use
resumable transfers--
a feature
I'll talk about in a bit--
having a higher level
of abstraction is nice,
and in addition to being nice,
it's also--
we use a reference-able
implementation
to let you see
a complete representation
of how to use the API.
Here's some code.
And for this,
our library level is BOTO.
BOTO's a popular
Open Source library
written in Python,
and here, what you can see,
is I'm going to get
the same object,
as you can see,
it's being requested
using the REST API,
but it's a higher level
of abstraction.
Basically,
you import a class
and instantiate an object
with that URI,
and then just print the content
out as a string.
In this case,
it's a pretty small object,
so printing it
as a string works.
And then
one level up from there,
I already mentioned gsutil
being a useful command,
but in addition to being
a useful command,
it also represents
a reference implementation
of how to use BOTO
for Google Storage,
and additionally
there's this "-d" option,
which is really handy.
It prints out all
the HTTP requests and responses,
not the actual payload, but just
the headers of the requests,
and that's really useful
both for just basically
understanding what the--
the protocol is doing,
and also, if you're trying
to troubleshoot some problem
in an application
you're implementing,
a lot of times,
this'll give you some details
about what's going on.
So let me give you a quick
demonstration of this.
If I look, first I have a copy
of that same BOTO program
that I showed you, that
reference-implementation slide,
and now I'm just
going to run this
using the Python interpreter.
You can see
it just retrieves--
it's a little short,
comma-separated value file,
and so that's running it
using Python.
You can go in
and separate points
and examine the state
of the program,
if you want, in Python.
And then the other thing
we can do here is,
I can use that same URL...
and now I'm just going to
CAT it using gsutil,
and you can see
I get the data out,
but before the data came out,
there's the--the request.
You can see the "GET,"
accepting coding,
authorization header,
the response,
a number of fields including,
for example,
the ETag which is a cryptic
affect track-check sum
that's used to help maintain
integrity of your data,
content type,
and so forth.
Okay, so that's
the reference implementations,
BOTO and gsutil.
Now, moving on, I want to talk
about security and sharing,
starting
with authentication.
So there's three ways
to authenticate requests,
OAuth2, which is the newest one
we're introducing today--
and I'll get to that in a fair
amount more depth later--
Web browser login,
which basically means
once you've logged
into any Google service,
that set of credentials
that you've logged in with
can be used to access
controlled content
from Google Storage.
So that's pretty convenient.
Once you're logged
into Gmail, for example,
you can also get
to your Google Storage.
And finally, HMAC-based
request signing,
and this is
a authentication mechanism
that depends on a shared secret
between you and Google Storage.
So here's another example
of a PUT-request to upload
an object to the Cloud,
and here I'm showing
a complete authorization header
using OAuth2 Standard.
This particular credential
is not valid.
It's just in the right format,
but it's just
to illustrate what an OAuth2
credential looks like.
So that's authentication.
Now, for access control,
the way access control works,
every bucket and every object
has an access control list
that specifies
who can access and do what
to the bucket and object,
and it's all controlled
using this--
this GET and PUT syntax
with a "? acl" at the end.
So, here's an example
for what you would see
if you retrieve a particular
object's ACL,
and I've highlighted
the parts
that are
particularly interesting.
First there's a grant
to the owner of this object,
"gsdemo2011@gmail.com,"
and that's a full control grant
which means that owner
can both read
and write the object
and also can read and write
the access control list.
And then
below that is a grant,
a group-based grant,
to this mailing list--
"gsdemo2011-guests
@googlegroups.com,"
and this is actually
a really powerful mechanism,
because what it means is,
you can set
an access control list
on many, many objects
and buckets,
say, millions of objects
and buckets
and then centrally
administer that
from the Google Groups console.
So this is a nice way
to do it, for example,
if you have
a bunch of objects
that need to be shared
by everybody in your company,
and as employees join
and leave the company,
you can just go edit
in one place
and affect the access control
for everything at once,
rather than having to go
individually edit ACLs
on individual objects.
Okay, so that's it
in a nutshell.
I've gone over the basic API,
and with that,
with GETs and PUTs
and the access control
and authentication mechanisms
I've talked about so far,
you can do a fair amount.
And that mostly was things
that were available last year,
although OAuth2 was not
until this year.
Now I want to talk about
some more advanced features.
The first one I want
to talk about is,
starting today,
you can request
that your data
be stored in Europe.
Before, you could only store
data in the United States,
and now, optionally,
if you specify
a location parameter using--
at bucket creation time,
you can specify
where the objects
are going to be located,
and it's as simple as that.
Once you've done that,
the rest of the API is the same.
In particular,
no one needs to know
where the bucket's located
to use it.
So, you make this decision--
where you're going
to put the bucket--
and then people can just use
the rest of the API,
and if you want,
you can look up
where a bucket's located
using this "? location" syntax.
Now, earlier
in the presentation,
Navneet mentioned that we
support strong data consistency
and here's where I think it
makes a really compelling case
for why that matters so much.
I mean, strong data
consistency matters
even if you're just using
buckets and--
in a nearby location, but
imagine the following scenario.
You have customers
all over the world
and a customer goes to upload
some data using HTTP form post
into the Cloud, and that--
that form post causes
a re-direct to a server
that you have that might be
running in the United States.
Now, Google Storage
is implemented
as a replicated set of servers
running all over the world,
and it's possible, and, in fact,
likely, in a scenario like this
that the Web server's
going to ask for the data
from a different server
than where the user uploaded to.
Strong data consistency says
that once
the data's been written,
anywhere you read it
in the world,
you're going to get
the most recent value.
That's as con--contrasted
with eventual consistency,
which only guarantees
you would see a value
that was current
at some time in the past
and will eventually come
up-to-date
if there are no more updates,
and strong data consistency
makes it much easier
to implement applications,
'cause you don't have to worry
what version of the data
they're looking at and so forth.
So next I want to talk
about a feature
called "resumable transfers."
And this is particularly useful
if you're uploading
and downloading
really large objects.
Suppose you're trying to upload,
for example, a terabyte,
and partway
through the upload, the--
your network connection
gets interrupted.
For example, you're walking
between meeting rooms,
and your laptop
goes through
an area of limited
Wi-Fi connectivity.
If your upload is interrupted,
with resumable transfer,
once you get back
into high-connectivity zone,
it can just resume again,
and that's nice,
because you don't waste
all the time
that you already put into--
suppose you already uploaded,
you know, 500 megabytes--
you don't waste the time
and the network expense
to re-upload that part of it.
And so here's the way
it works.
When you start
a resumable upload,
the server will give you back
an upload ID,
and if it gets interrupted,
you can use that upload ID,
you can see it on the end
of the URL there,
during the PUT request
and in response to that--
this is the Google Data
resumable protocol--
Google's server will tell you
how many bytes it currently has,
and then you can follow up
by putting a range--
content range PUT
with the rest of the content.
So that's how
resumable upload works.
Resumable download uses
the standard HTTP range
GET request to do
a similar thing.
In this case, you don't need
to ask the server.
You can tell what--
how many bytes you have
locally on your disc,
and you can just ask for the
bytes that you don't yet have.
So, now what I want to do
is give you a demonstration
of both European buckets
and of resumable transfers,
and for this, I have
a couple of windows open,
in two different cities,
one in London and one Dallas.
These are on machines that are
off of Google's network,
and the first thing
I'm going to do
is I'm going to create
a bucket...
using this "-l" syntax,
saying in location "Europe."
If you don't specify
a location,
the default
is the United States.
And I'm just going
to call it "gseu."
So, I've created a bucket,
and immediately,
I can go over to Dallas now,
and I can see
the bucket's there.
Now I'm going to go back
over to London...
and I'm going to upload.
I have a file locally
that's 50 megabytes.
And you can see,
as it's uploading,
it's giving
you a progress report.
I'm going to interrupt it
at about 35 megabytes in
and start it back up.
And you can see it started
right back up where it left off.
So that was
a resumable upload.
And now, as soon as
the upload is finished...
I'm going to download it.
And you can see the file
is immediately available,
and it's--the download's
going a bit slower,
because it's going
across the Atlantic now.
And I'm going to interrupt
this download
and start it back up again.
And you can see it picked
back up at four megabytes,
where it left off.
So, that quick demonstration
showed creating
and using buckets,
that they're
immediately visible.
Once you've created in London,
I can immediately start using it
in Dallas, and you--
I could do resumable uploads
and downloads.
Okay, the next new topic
I wanted to talk about
is OAuth2.
We've mentioned it
a few times now.
What is OAuth2?
Well, it's a widely adopted
open standard
for both authentication
and authorization, okay?
So it's being used--
Google is moving
all its APIs over
to support OAuth2,
and it's not just in Google.
It's more widely used
outside of Google as well.
It's a widely adopted
open standard,
and the thing
that's really powerful,
there's a number of things
that are nice features about it,
but one of the things
that's really powerful
in my mind about OAuth2
is that you can authorize
a Web app to act on your behalf
without giving
your login credentials away.
So think about it.
This is important.
If the way I gave access
to Google Storage
was to give it
my login and password,
that would mean whatever
account was going to go access--
whatever application was going
to go access Google Storage
could also,
if it was unscrupulous,
go access my Gmail,
my Buzzes, my Docs,
everything else
that's all locked
behind that authorization,
those credentials.
Instead,
what OAuth2 lets you do
is authorize
a particular application
only to access
Google Storage.
It can't also access
all these other services.
So it's a much narrower scope
of authorization,
so that's, in general,
a better security practice.
And you can authorize
different applications
with different tokens
and revoke individual ones
if you want to.
And finally,
in order to implement OAuth2,
you don't need to do
any request signing,
and if anybody's ever tried
implementing request signing
using OAuth1 or HMAC,
you know it's kind of tricky
to get all the details right.
Okay, so those are the new
features I wanted to talk about,
and now, to try
to pull it all together
and give you a better idea
of what you could do
with all these capabilities
we're talking about,
I want to present
an end-to-end scenario.
And here's the scenario.
It's a photographer's
preview service,
and so think of it this way.
Photographer goes
and shoots photos
at an event like a wedding
or like this conference here
and then wants to make
the photos available to people
who attended the event,
and there's a few different
access control things
that we want to do about that.
First of all,
we only want to let users see
a watermarked version
of the photo,
because the photographer's
actually going to try
to sell the photo,
so we want to make a photo
that the user can recognize
but has a big mark
across the middle
so they don't have any desire
to just keep that version
of the photo.
And we also want to make it
so the only people
that can see
those preview photos
are the people
that attended the event.
We don't really want it globally
visible to the whole world.
So that's the basic idea
of the service,
and it demonstrates
a number of things.
I'm going to show you
using team-based development
and management to build
this application and deploy it.
I'm going to show
domain named buckets,
so you can make buckets
with a domain name in it,
and this is useful
if you want to brand
the service or application
you're deploying
as being run as you,
as opposed to something
that's in Google.
I'm going to show you
OAuth2 authorization,
and I'm going to show you
group-based sharing
using Google Groups'
infrastructure.
So, the first step in this is
my IT guy comes along,
and he's going to
set everything up
so then the developers
can work on it.
And the first step is he's
going to go create a project
and register an application
with Google's author--
authorization infrastructure,
and once he's done that,
he's going to verify
that he's the domain owner
so that he can create a bucket.
Google will prevent people
other than you
from creating a bucket
with your domain name.
Okay, so let me give you
a demonstration of this.
So, this is the Google API
console again,
the place that we were looking
at earlier in the talk,
and the first thing I'm going
to do is I'm going to...
set up API access.
So when you click
on that link,
you can ask it
to create credentials.
I'm just going to create
a product name.
I don't have a logo for it.
And it's a Web application.
And I'm going to tell it
to create a client ID.
And at this point--
Now, it's got
a not very pretty formatting
'cause the window's so large,
but essentially there's
this client ID and a secret,
and those two pieces
of information
you can stick
in your application
so that it can request
credentials on behalf of a user
and the authorization
service can know
that that's
this particular client.
And that secret
in and of itself
actually doesn't gain access
to anything.
It's basically
just to identify the client
that you've just created.
Okay, so I've set up an API.
I set up API access
for my new application,
and now I'm going to set up
the team.
And. actually, I've already
added the two people here.
I've added
a couple of developers
and given them edit access.
You can give them
view or edit access.
And what this does is
it makes it so that once the--
once you've set up this team,
anytime you go create a bucket,
anybody who has edit access
in the team
will have edit access
to the bucket.
So it just makes
setting up ACLs easier,
among other things.
Okay, so that's
what the IT person's done.
He's gone and created
the project
and registered the app,
and now the next step
I want to do is set up domain--
a domain-named bucket,
and for this...
I have a little script.
So the first thing I'm going
to do is show you what happens
if you were to try to
create a bucket
with a domain name in it that
I don't have authorization for.
So I don't own the domain
"example.com."
Google Storage detects that.
When you try to create
the bucket "example.com,"
it says you need to go
to this URL to--
to prove that you own
the bucket,
and if you do, it would take you
to a page that gives--
that explains
what domain ownership is
and gives you
several different options.
I'm not going to go
to that page now.
Instead, I'm just going to
show you the result
of having already done that
for my gsdemo2011.com domain.
So here what I did was,
when I visited the doma--
Webmaster tools domain
ownership verification page,
it generated
a little text token,
which you can see down at
the bottom of the screen here,
and asked me to write
that into my domain name server.
And the fact that I'm able
to do that proves to--
to Google
that I own the domain.
And there's other options, too.
You don't need to do it
just using domain updates.
Once I've done that,
I can now go create a bucket,
and Google Storage
will allow me to do it.
So I'm creating this bucket
"photos.gsdemo2011.com"
and at that point,
the IT guy's job is complete.
He's set up the project,
created the team,
set up the bucket,
and now we can move on
and bring in
the development team.
Here's my development team.
And they're going to go
implement the application,
and they're going to test it
using an access control list
called--mechanism called
"project-private,"
which basically means
anybody in the team
can read and write
the bucket
and see everything
that's being created in there,
but it's not yet visible
to the rest of the world
because we're still
in the process,
developing and de-bugging
this application.
Once they finish doing that,
they can deploy
the app into App Engine
and start using it.
Okay, so the next step now is
we've got this app up
and running
using this bucket
that we've set up,
and now we have a photographer
who's going to go along--
come along and use the app.
And the way that works is,
the photographer's going to go
to App Engine and run the app,
and the first thing
it's going to do
is notice that the app
doesn't yet have credentials
for that photographer.
It's going to request those
via Google's
authorization infrastructure,
and that is going to
in turn require
that the user
authorize the access.
So you're not just giving it
credentials
to work with
without first verifying
that the user wants that
to be done.
Okay, so here
I'm going to show this.
So what I have here--
first of all,
notice that this is a--
I'm logged into Gmail here
as this identity pix--
the photographer
"pix@gsdemo2011.com,"
and I'm going to go
run this app engine app.
This is an application
that I've uploaded
to Google's App Engine,
and what it does is it's going
to try to acquire credentials.
And the first thing
it's going to notice
is it doesn't have credentials
that are authorized yet for me.
So it's saying,
"Do you want to authorize
this application GoogleIO Demo
to access Google Storage
for developers?"
And if you click, you can find
a little bit more information
about what
it's actually saying.
Do you want to manage data
and so forth?
And you can also see what's
going to happen once you do.
So, in particular,
what happened was
I went from App Engine,
App Engine noticed
it didn't have credentials
and redirected to Google's
authorization server.
You can see it's logged in--
it's "@accounts.google.com,"
and after authorizing,
it's going to redirect
back to my app,
down an app spot
but a different entry point,
which is the entry point that
will receive the credentials
that are generated.
So I'm going to allow
this access.
And at this point,
the application's
receiving the credentials,
it's going to store them
away securely
in the App Engine credential's
repository,
and it's going to use
those credentials
to read and write buckets
and store this--
this watermarked photo.
And now it's saying the photo's
available at this link.
And since I'm the person
who ran this app,
I can go ahead and click on
this link and get to the photo.
And now I want to make
one other point,
which is the comment
I just made about,
"Since I'm the one who ran it,
I can look at it."
Let me bring up
a different window here.
Now, you remember
that previous window
was logged in
as the photographer.
The photographer
ran the app,
generated
the watermarked photos.
Now I want to see
the view of the data
that was generated
by this app
from someone
other than the photographer.
So here's my IT login,
and here I have positioned
in the address bar
that same photo URL,
and if I try to go there,
I get "Access Denied,"
and that's because
when the app wrote the photo,
it wrote it with an ACL
that granted read access
to anybody that was
in the "gsdemo-2011-guests
@googlegroups.com" group,
and this identity
is not yet logged in there.
So let me show what--
show you what happens.
I'm going to go sign up.
So I'm over
at the Google Groups console
under "gsdemo2011-guests,"
and I'm going to go
join this group.
And you can also try this
if you want.
I promise I'm not going to
harvest anyone's email.
This is just
a little demonstration.
I'm going to join this group.
And once I've done that,
I can go back and refresh,
and now I can access the photo.
So, again, this is demonstrating
that you can share with a group,
and there's actually that--
that group-sharing mechanism,
actually,
there's a couple different ways
you can set it up.
The way I have it
set up right now,
it just lets anybody
who wants to go log in and--
and sign up
to be in the group.
And that implements,
for example,
if you wanted a registry
of everybody
who tried to access
this photo.
A different way
of setting it up
would be to have
a central administrator
who decides who gets to be
in the group,
and that's what
you'd want to do,
for example, if you were
a company that was setting up
the access control mechanism
I mentioned before
where you have
millions of objects
all set with the same grant
to a particular group,
and then you can just add
and remove people
from that group
from here.
So there's two very different
kinds of access control models
you can implement with this.
Okay, so...
And that's pretty much it.
That's the part I just
showed you
with the guests that join
and can view
the photos and so forth.
Okay, so moving on...
Now I want to talk
a little bit more
about what actually
happened with OAuth,
and I'm not going to get into
a lot of depth about this.
If you want to learn more
about OAuth2,
I recommend--
There's a session
about identity and OAuth2
that's going to be tomorrow--
I think tomorrow afternoon
at 1:45.
You can check
your schedule.
But let me just give you
a brief overview.
So what happened was,
we set up the application,
and the Google
authorization service
set up a set up credentials
that we wrote
into the application,
and then when the photographer
runs the application,
it gets--
the app redirects
to Google Storage, to Google's
authentication service,
which then generates
a revocable token.
It's called a "refresh token,"
and that token can be used
with an exchange protocol,
which, again, I encourage you
to go to the OAuth2 talk if
you want to learn more about it,
to actually generate the--
the what's called
an "access token"
to access the protected storage,
Google Storage in this case.
And one of the important
points to note here
is that access token
is short-lived,
and by default, it lives
for only an hour.
So you're never actually
sharing long-lived credential
with a protected resource,
which, again, is another
nice security feature.
And one other comment
I'd make is,
if you get the--the latest
version of gsutil,
which we just made available,
it includes a sub-directory
called "cloudauth"
that has a complete
implementation of a Web app
that does OAuth2-based
authorization
to talk to Google Storage
from Google App engine.
Okay, so just the recap
of some of the
business/developer-oriented
features
that we've announced
and talked about today.
Support for large
and streaming transfers,
the ability to specify an
additional location in Europe,
projects
and team-based development
via Google's API console,
ownership verification
for domain name buckets,
and then, finally, security,
both OAuth2 and group sharing.
So, at this point,
I invite people to go sign up.
Again, this link is going to--
the link that this takes you to,
the actual sign-up page
will be live this afternoon,
and if anybody
has any questions,
I'd like to open up
the floor now.
And if people have questions,
we would appreciate it
if you'd use one of
the two mics here, by the way.
man:
Put the URL back up, Mike.
Joneja:
Okay, put the URL back up.
man:
I have a question for you.
What does the pricing scheme
look like
for GETS, PUTS, POSTS,
all that jazz?
Joneja:
So you can go to--
Sorry, the question was about
pricing for GETS, PUTS, POSTS,
I guess, storage
and bandwidth as well.
So the information
is on our Website,
but just a quick highlight is,
storage costs
17 cents a gigabyte,
regardless
of where you store it.
Transfer into Google's ser--
data centers
is 10 cents a gigabyte.
Transfer out depends on
where you're transferring to.
It's 15 cents per gigabyte
in the US and Europe
and 30 in Asia,
and then requests are charged--
the read-type requests
are charged at 1 cent
per 10,000 requests,
and the write-type requests
are charged at 1 cent
per thousand requests.
man: Hi. I'm curious
whether you see this
as a service
that's meant to be consumed
on the back end by a Web app
or by users through a browser
with a latency kind of support
dealing with large files
in real time for a Web app.
Schwartz:
So the question was,
Web app versus end users making
use of the service.
You can use it for either.
I mean, we're more tailored
towards developers building,
you know,
scalable applications,
so in that sense,
it's more
of a back-end infrastructure,
but certainly
we have use cases
of users accessing the data
directly from the browser.
We actually have a manager,
a Google Storage manager,
which is a web-based UI
for browsing as an end user,
and I actually use it,
for example,
for moving data up and down
into my home for the Cloud.
Yeah.
man:
I have an Android app
that I want to upload a file
directly into Google Docs.
Is there a way to do that?
I mean, it seemed like this
might be a lower-level API.
Is there something
in the Android SDK
that allows me to send the file
into a user's--
Schwartz:
Into Docs?
man:
Into a user's GDocs?
Schwartz:
So GDocs and Google Storage
are separate services.
They don't share data.
There might be a way to do
what you're talking about
using the GData protocols,
but it's not through
Google Storage.
man: Thank you.
Schwartz: Yeah.
man: Why should I prefer
to use a Storage
instead of the Blobstore
on App Engine's application?
Schwartz: I'm sorry.
I couldn't--
man: Why I should
prefer the Storage
instead of Blobstore
on App Engine?
Schwartz: Well, actually
we're working with App Engine--
So the question was,
why should you prefer to use
Google Storage
rather than talking
to App Engine's Blobstore.
We're working
with the App Engine team
to integrate the two
so that they'll be the same,
and it'll basically just come
down to being your choice
of whether you want to use
App Engine or Google Storage API
to get the data there,
but once it's there,
it should be accessible
by both.
That's not currently
the state of things.
We're working on that.
man: All right.
Would you work on providing
the Image API on top of Storage,
which is very good?
Joneja:
So the question was,
will we work on supporting
the Images API
on top of Google Storage?
So I can't comment
about future directions,
but, you know, you could assume
that if we're working
on those features
in one--in App Engine,
once the integration happens,
you'll be able to use it
all over.
man: So, in your demo--
in your demo,
where you uploaded the file
to a European data center...
Schwartz:
Mm-hmm.
man: and downloaded it
from the US,
that file is being served
from that European data center
directly, right?
I guess
the first question is--
Schwartz: Well, the data lives
in the European data center.
The exact mechanics
of how things are served
are really something
we can't comment about,
but I mean, yeah, it does live
in the European data center.
man: You saw slow download
speeds from that US client.
Schwartz:
Right, right.
man:
Does that eventually get better?
Is that replicated
to a US end point
and downloaded from there?
Schwartz: So you can turn on
caching if you want.
By default, it's not on,
and the--
no, the data is not replicated
to the US.
We, you know, keep it in
Europe for a variety of reasons,
if you ask it
to be placed in Europe.
Joneja: So I'll build
on Mike's statement
and add that, you know,
data is always replicated,
but the way we do replication
is within a region,
and so we have two regions,
the US region
and the Europe region,
so you will have replicas
of your data
in multiple data centers
when you store it in Europe,
but those data centers
will all be in Europe.
Now, talking
about performance,
there's probably
a bunch of things going on
between Dallas and Europe.
I'm not sure
what was happening today,
maybe network congestion
or something,
but in general, performance
should be pretty fast.
man: I have a question
on the large data sets.
So, if I'm starting with,
say, hundreds of terabytes
at the onset of my app, is--
Amazon today
offers a opportunity
where I can send them a drive,
and they'll load that for me.
Will Google offer something
similar to that?
Schwartz:
So, again--
man: Initial data load
for a very large size?
Schwartz:
Right.
Again, we can't comment
on future offerings,
but we're definitely looking
at lots of different things
like that,
and we're very interested--
If anybody has ideas of things
they'd like to be able to work,
come talk to us.
You know,
we're always interested
in hearing
what your needs are.
man: I think you may have
already answered it
with, "Can't comment
on future directions."
Asia coming online
anytime soon?
Schwartz: Again,
a future direction.
[laughter]
Sorry.
man: Hello.
Yeah.
I have one question.
I'm curious
about the performance,
and for improved performance,
have you considered to use
some peer-to-peer technology
to take advantage
of some storaging in the user,
in--in user space?
Schwartz: So, the question
is whether we've considered
using peer-to-peer technology
to make performance faster
by taking advantage of users
that might be near you that have
already downloaded it.
No.
We're not doing that.
Joneja:
We don't do that,
and, again,
as we spoke about, you know,
future directions,
we don't comment.
However, having said that,
if you have thoughts and input
on things
that you would like us do to
and use cases you'd like us
to support,
please do feel free
to keep suggesting them.
Either find us
after the session
or post them to
the GS discussion mailing list,
and we monitor
that list pretty closely.
man:
Okay, thank you.
man #2: Hi, what kind of APIs
do you guys have
for dealing
with a relational database
and keeping records synched.
So, if I wanted two, say,
SQL server databases
synchronized
in different places,
do you have any specific APIs
for dealing with that?
Schwartz:
Well, that's definitely
not part of Google Storage.
Google Storage API
is really just a storage,
not a database API.
There's various
other kinds of, you know,
products inside of Google
that do database-like things,
but that's not part
of Google Storage.
man:
Thank you.
man #2: Will you have the--
the capability to cap,
say, items
per authentication?
So, say, for instance,
I use a Kindle
and downloaded it once or twice
based on their authentication,
would you have that
as a feature?
Schwartz: Are you talking
about limiting how much
a user might end up costing
because you put a limit
on how many things they can do?
man:
Yes, yes.
Schwartz: So, again,
it's a--
do you want to comment on that?
Joneja: I mean, thanks.
Thanks for the question.
I guess that the short answer
is, again,
you know,
"future directions."
Don't comment too much
about it.
But, you know, come
and find me afterwards.
Let's chat about what
you want to do,
and I'd love to just understand
what you're trying to do,
and we can see, you know,
if there's something--
Schwartz: Yeah.
We'll both be here
for the next couple days,
by the way.
Thank you.
man: How you doing?
Your demo showed
resuming file transfers.
Schwartz:
Mm-hmm.
man: So it looks like
your system can accommodate
ordered operations,
and is there, like,
perhaps, a head request where
you can get, like, file length
so you can create
your own chunking mechanism?
It looks like it's all happening
under the hood in gsutil.
Schwartz: Yeah, yeah.
There is a head mechanism,
and, actually,
when I scrolled back
and showed you the operations
that were going on
using that "gsuitl-d,"
I didn't scroll back
far enough.
The underlying
BOTO library call
actually ended up doing a head
before it did the CAT,
so, yes, you can.
man: So that's what it's
actually going to do--
resume so it figures out
its place in the file,
so it knows
it's getting something--
Schwartz: Oh, actually,
for resumable upload,
it's not using head,
it's using a request
to the server
to ask what the server has.
It's using that Google
resumable protocol.
So it's basically,
when you start the transfer,
the server gives you back
an upload ID,
which is just a GUID, basically,
a globally unique ID.
You--you make a--
when you PUT again it--
you specify that GUID,
and the server gives you
a response back saying
what it currently has,
so it's not using head for that.
man:
Thanks.
Schwartz: And that's
a more general protocol
than just Google Storage,
by the way.
That's used
throughout Google.
For example, when you upload
attachments with Gmail,
it uses that same protocol.
man: Hi.
I have a couple questions.
Does Google Storage
support transport encryption
and on-site encryption?
And my other question was
related to a previous question
about do you store metadata
along with the files
that you upload?
Schwartz:
So the first question was,
do we support
transport encryption?
And, yes, we do, and, in fact,
we encourage it.
Particularly with OAuth2,
you want to leave using HTTPS.
You want to encrypt
the payload,
including the credential
information.
I think the second question
was asking whether
we store data encrypted.
Was that...?
So, we don't, right now.
We're, you know, it's--
We can't comment
about future offerings,
but that's not the case
right now.
And the third one I think
was about storing metadata.
Was that right?
man: Along with
each individual file.
Schwartz:
Yeah, so you can store
limited amounts of metadata.
You can actually
set headers on objects
when you PUT the object,
and you can only do that
when you create an object.
The objects are immutable,
so you can't take an object
and then, you know,
overwrite parts of it.
You just write an object
with the headers.
man:
Thank you.
Joneja: So, can I build
on your second answer as well,
just to your question
about storing data encrypted?
So, you know, I--
I do want to, you know--
a specific call out
that we do take, you know,
strong security precautions
with your data.
You know, you've probably
seen the video of us
destroying
our hard drives, right?
There's one on YouTube.
But, you know, in general,
the data store encoded,
so even if you got hold
of a hard drive,
you wouldn't be able to do
anything with it,
but it's not encrypted.
Like, it's not
strongly encrypted.
man: Hi. I have a question
about the business model.
Does it support MSPs,
or if I'm a third-party data
management provider,
is there a support for
that kind of a business model,
in terms of whether
it be pricing
or how we control
credentials,
and do we have to set up
a different account
for every customer that we have
or client of ours?
Schwartz:
Why don't you go on that one?
Joneja: Could you just help me
understand the scenario again,
one more time?
man: So, for example, if I'm
a data management vendor...
Joneja:
Mm-hmm.
man: ...and I want to provide
data services for,
you know,
my client bases.
Joneja: Mm-hmm.
man: I have 100 customers.
Is there a business model
that supports that,
or do I have to set up--
Is it going to be like
a brute force
of different accounts
for each customer,
or do they have to do it
for themselves,
or can I do it for them?
Joneja: That's a great question,
and, in fact,
let's talk after the session,
and I'd like to understand more
about what you're trying to do,
and we'll see if there's
something we can do.
man: You talked
about using your home data
and synching it
to Google Storage.
Are you using, like,
rsync or anything to keep
that data synchronized,
or is that a possibility yet?
Schwartz:
It's not using rsync.
There are
third-party tools available
that do a form
of synchronization.
They look at time stamps and--
and MD5s and ETags.
I think the one I use
is S3Sync.
Yeah, but it's not using rsync.
It's not that protocol.
man: Okay.
Schwartz: Yeah.
man: Thank you.
Schwartz:
Yeah, and actually,
I think there are also
some other third-party tools
that are out there
that work with Google Storage
that give you
a nicer, kind of gooey interface
for doing synchronization.
Any other questions?
Okay, well, if not, we're going
to stick around for a while,
if anyone wants to come
talk to us individually,
or feel free to come grab us
out in the halls,
and thanks again for coming.
[applause]